how to be more convincing
so i got a great question from our
youtube viewers love you guys
qui stock network i hope i pronounced
that okay
think you could do a video on how to be
more convincing if you already have let
me know
so how to be more convincing the thing
with being convincing it's not going to
come from how much
data you throw at somebody it's not
going to come from
all the proof and all the stats it comes
from your confidence
you have to be confident if you are
confident
in what you're selling people will be
convinced they'll believe you
if you hesitate if you're not sure then
you start to raise doubts
and that's the difference so how do you
become confident in what you're selling
it starts with believing in what you're
doing right believe
you have to believe in what you're doing
if you don't really believe in the
product you're selling
you're not going to be that confident
and you're not going to be that
convincing right
you have to know that it works you know
that it works for you
and you know that has worked for other
people you have to really be confident
and believe that your solution is going
to help this person
when you're talking to somebody and you
see that they have a real problem
remember
business is all about value right you're
giving value you're making money
because you're offering real value to
your customers you're helping them solve
an important problem in their life
whatever it is you have to know
and really feel deep down that what
you're selling
is going to solve their problem and make
them feel happy
if you're not entirely confident about
that
you're not going to be convincing if you
don't even believe it yourself
you don't really feel it yourself how
can you convince somebody else to feel
it
doesn't make sense so that starts with
you believing it
the second part is going to just be
practice
practice getting used to how you say
things getting used to the types of
questions that come back and being able
to handle it
thinking about your own personal stories
that you can share
practice but the main part is really
believe in what you're doing
so let me give you an example i have a
series of mastermind groups
these are groups that i run here in
toronto and we meet once a month we help
each other with our businesses our
entrepreneurs come together
and we try to help each other out when i
was first
talking to people about the groups when
i was first running the groups i would
always be in a suit
you know i would always wear a suit i
always felt like you know i have to be
the professional one i've got to wear
the suit
and i wasn't as confident in the idea so
i felt like
i guess the suit made me feel a little
bit more confident professional
and over the years as i saw how the
groups worked
and i know that the groups work because
i see great results we've seen
businesses go from
just an idea on paper to now being you
know million dollar plus
companies and they credit their success
to the mastermind group so i know it
works
and i know that i'm doing it for the
right reason and i look at entrepreneurs
who come and meet me and i can tell if
they're gonna benefit or not
i can tell if they're gonna if this will
solve their problem or not
so i have the confidence and now when i
go i might be wearing my belief shirt
i might be in the hoodie with jeans on
like i don't need
the dress up to feel confident because i
know
that it works and i have to practice
the discussion i know every question
they're going to ask i have every story
ready to go because i have the
experience and practice but
more importantly i have the confidence
to know
if i can help them or not and if i can't
i tell them like you know what
this group isn't for you either they're
too small
or they're too big or the personality is
not the right fit
or i just don't think it's going to work
and i'll tell them
and that's okay too so remember
business is about value you have to help
your customers
you have to make them you have to solve
their pain
solve their problem and if you can do
that and you know
you can do that and you're confident
when you're talking to them
then they'll sign up you don't have to
convince them of anything
because they believe too belief for
those of you watching like the video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think please leave a comment ask me a
question underneath to make a video
response
and you can click on my face to
subscribe to the channel see more videos
like this
thank you so much i'll see you soon